[Music]
guys welcome back to another episode of
chappelle's world
i am he i used to say that on my last
podcast
i'm like well i used to go welcome back
to his man he's with chapel they see i
am he
i got that from noah gallagher because
he said that one time to some fan
because some fan was like are you no
gallagher no they said are you the guy
from oasis he said i am he and i thought
that was the coolest thing to ever say
i am he and i am here welcome back man i
can't start this podcast off without
talking about this
um
rest in peace taylor hawkins from the
foo fighters
that was a man that's a that's a tough
one
you know and i'm not saying like listen
if you don't you're not food fighters
whatever blah blah blah
being a you know
foo fighters fan yes that's a
extremely
tough one i
man the way i found out
was okay so i'm getting ready to film
this set
um
for this this
thing called don't tell comedy a bunch
of secret shows or whatever they run
these shows and
it's pretty dope but they do this like
they're doing this like film
these
filming of sets that they release online
blah blah blah
and so they have all their production
there and camera like there's people
taking pictures this guy taking pictures
and the guy that was taking pictures
just right before i was walking on stage
he goes uh
he goes what's up man uh
he goes you're a big fan uh and he goes
you're also really good at guitar man i
love watching you play guitar
and it was so funny because i was like
how did you know i could play guitar he
goes the internet i was like you're
right you're right
okay boomer okay
he called me with a boomer moment okay i
was like how did you know that he's the
internet i like how he said the internet
and not online
just to really diminish
the fact that i just make you feel even
dumber yeah yeah he's like into the
internet
the thing that's been been out since i
don't even know when it wouldn't
internet create or wouldn't it when did
the internet you gonna edit that out no
sir when did the internet create is that
what i should type into no don't do it
don't do it
anyways uh
then he was like yeah man it's it's cool
uh
you know
that you also do all all this other
stuff uh outside of comedy and uh he
goes yeah we listen a lot of same music
man foo fighters and
and then i was like oh yeah i love the
foo fighters you know and he goes uh
yeah man did you did you hear what
happened to taylor i was like oh no you
know
and the way he said it i was just
thinking like maybe he wanted like one
something or you know i don't know
the energy he delivered
didn't seem like the news he he
delivered and he goes
oh yeah man he died and i go
i go that's what you wanted to tell me
before i go on stage it was like
literally right before
i'm like the the because i was the
second comedian and the comedian was ju
he just had got the light to get off
and then that guy tells me that and my
heart
sank
it sank i go
what
no
no
no no no no no no and then obviously
what's the first thing you do go to your
phone you go to google or lugal if
you've seen hot tub time machine
you haven't oh okay
uh deep breath the the people listening
now but um
and then sure enough man and meanwhile
at the top of my set i do like a quick
foo fighters joke
that's right
oh yeah yeah you've seen me you've seen
me perform you've seen me perform uh uh
casey has seen me perform before yeah
right at the top so what did you do did
you have to reference it like well you i
kept thinking backstage i was just like
i shouldn't do that joke
but meanwhile i was like man i feel like
it's going to throw me off because
already i'm already like off rhythm
because of like how i feel about
you know taylor and just thinking about
that band
and um
i was just like well i i did it i did it
anyway and no it's not a dis
it's not it's it's a funny reference
about me
and i use
foo fighters as like to give you an idea
of something you know so don't come up
here and try to [ __ ] slap me
uh
[Laughter]
excuse my
language anyways so
i
you know i i did the joke anyway i just
i was just like okay i'll i'll do
i'll do the joke
because not no not everybody knew
because everybody was in the showroom
like just watching the show and i think
it just had got announced like
when the dude that had told me and
meanwhile
the some of the production team that
were like that was there that knows who
i am
they specifically said hey taylor
hawkins died don't tell chappelle lacy
they literally said that that's how well
they know me
that's how well they know me and
i'm telling you i love that that's the
band i've seen the most
that's the band
as a
out of all the artists i've yeah that i
listened to actually it's a well it's
like it was it was neck and neck between
them and gbh the british punk band but
that was the band i've seen the most and
i've got to me i've gotten to meet in
the band and i've got to like perform on
the same
festival as that band like doing comedy
and so like it was just it was just
insane i was just like i
i don't know my heart literally
literally sank
you know and then i was i was backstage
and you know i was talking to people
about because they could really feel
that i was messed up they could really
feel like oh wow proposals really
yeah
i am i i mean it's it's uh for me
you know i i know people
like tend to do this thing where they go
well it's a celebrity
you know so why are people all these but
it's like no no it's it's
all on what the person has delivered out
to the world
you know what i mean yeah like when norm
mcdonald died for example like i was
bombed i didn't even i didn't expect to
have to be so bummed yeah it's like you
don't realize how impactful
someone is even whether or not you
actually know them or have met them in
that way know them personally like yeah
it's like
and it's like you don't necessarily have
to know a per know the person but if the
person has done something
for you
to
feel good about
who you are they make you happy if they
make you happy and they have they bring
this when you think of this person or
this entertainer or that actor or
actress or whoever it may be and when
you think of them you think of him like
oh when i when i look at that person i
just smile
when i see what they're doing i just
smile and if and if that person does
that for you
yeah you have the right to feel bummed
about it you know i know i i a lot of
times yeah people can
we'll do this thing where it's like
oh you didn't even know the person and
it's like
no i didn't but i know what they did for
me i know how they made me feel
you know what i mean like you don't
necessarily get to know him it's like
man that's a
it's a big one
that's a big for me man i mean
what yeah the first time i saw them was
like 2011.
that was the first concert i ever teared
up at
yeah no joke it was like
but with a smile on my face you know
and i just held it and it just
and then i was wearing a hey i was
wearing a colored shirt so you could see
the tears
and then i never watched that shirt
because that's a foo fighter tear
you know what i mean
a foo fight tear a foo
casey
came through
with an absolute
banger of uh
what do you call those jokes no pun
pun yes yeah it's fun yeah good yeah fun
i almost said on tundra way off you use
that too liberally you're always
throwing around on tundra am i really
yeah you're never right when you use it
either no i don't correct you yeah
you're having fun
you don't correct it you don't edit it
out you leave it in you let the people
know like hey chappelle's not the
smartest person
no you are just
you're just too liberal with the antonio
you don't know what it means and it's
fine
anyways man that that yeah that was a
that was a warrior while you were on
stage performing were you like
because i i've heard from comics they
can kind of go autopilot with their act
and be thinking kind of in the
background so were you thinking about
that while i was i was super out of um
autopilot
with it like i just felt like i was kind
of i honestly felt like i was kind of
blacked out on stage
yeah
yeah oh for sure i for sure felt like
that because it was just like
you whenever like that feeling hits your
body you like your body like you you
feel it throughout your body you feel
this like rush or you feel like i i
don't know how to explain the feeling
it's like a
not a numbness but just like a like a
like oh my gosh you know is is the word
i could use for it
you know and i hope that you guys
understand that
but uh but yeah it just kind of like
blacked out
did my jokes
you know the set was really really good
you know
but it just it just yeah it was weird
yeah it wasn't it was in the back of my
head
that's a fair question
wow
you're really good at this
try try you should be like the next
jerry springer or something
you are not the father
well not way off you know
you're in that world yeah
but man yeah
that was that was a tough one and the
the nicest dudes and i know everybody
says that but genuinely the nicest dudes
it's it's always cool when someone
you know can be
this big thing to you
and you look at them in awe
and then when you meet them they're just
the nicest person
that's like my favorite thing
so yeah uh
it man it's such a crazy crazy history
with that because
i don't know how much you know about the
foo fighters but taylor is their second
drummer
okay
and so
the original drummer
obviously dave grohl
known to be one of the [ __ ]
one of the top you know rock and roll
drummers
of all time
you know comes from one of the biggest
bands of all time
you know yeah it'd be hard to be his
drummer
it'd be it'd be tough to be dave gross
dave grohl's drummer
you know what i mean because he's he's
you know constantly looking back at you
like
i can make that sound better you know i
don't i don't know you know so the fact
that like taylor
the cool thing about taylor is like
dave was a fan of him
you know he was originally an alanis
morissette i don't know if you knew that
yeah he originally played for atlantis
more set
and he uh
dave was like hey man
you know
our drummer left we need a new drummer
you know do you know anybody isn't that
ironic
two for two two for two
casey is two
four
two
gosh do not mess with this man do not
mess with this man for the next 45
minutes or hour or however long we do
this all right do not mess with them uh
just don't mess with them at all but uh
but no yeah so and taylor i guess taylor
was like i'll drum for you
because he liked the foo fighters
everybody liked the foo fighters so it's
just a dope story and then the fact that
like
taylor could fulfill dave dave's needs
in a and above and above and beyond that
to being a great drummer
so that's a tough one man let's take a
break from this episode to talk about
happy hippo
okay i started using kratom kratom to
fire up my brain before any shows uh
whether it be stand-up or singing
or just my podcast it's like a limitless
pill for me uh one of the best
focused products i've ever used best
part is that it's all natural so you
don't have to worry about anything crazy
going in your body so everybody wants
natural
visit
happyhippos.com and use promo code
thickboy for 20 off for life use that
code as many times as you want once
again that's
happyhippos.com using promo code dickboy
for 20 off for life
sorry i had to start off some you know
emo but that was a
that one got me no i'm not gonna lie
that one that one that one punched me in
the gut you know
maybe that's why i've had an upset
stomach for you know
since
saturday friday
since friday because saturday
saturday was good saturday was good
saturday was the debut of my band mad
peaceful
that's how i walked out
[Laughter]
and then the band just started playing
[Laughter]
does anybody still say hit it no i don't
think though no not no i don't think so
not especially not in the type of music
i do
hit it maybe google dolls is like hit it
could you whisper in my ear you know
they probably do that but yeah
saturday was the debut of mad
peaceful
crazy dude it was insane
i i
another blackout moment yeah
in a sense it was it was dope so we
performed at this skate shop called
program skate shop it's in fullerton
and well it's a skate shop slash record
store
you know which is like bands of
you know hardcore punk rock world
usually
you know start off in like not
necessarily start off or like
but just perform
in places like that it's it's like of
the culture you know it's not it's not a
weird thing and actually a lot of bands
perform at record stores
you know but a record store skate shop
who's doing that you know but
uh needless to say it was it was cool
it rem it was the same feeling i got
when i did stand-up comedy when it was
like the first time i did stand-up was
like oh i wrote these things
on a piece of paper
and then went out on stage and did that
and people were receptive to it so it
was like cool i was like oh okay i
respect this
you know and then uh
that's
how i feel about
you know
on saturday i
wrote some songs created some songs with
you know some other guys
and uh yeah cause that's what they're
called
yeah i'm changing the band
this is chappelle they seeing the other
guys
got a nice ring to it huh yeah there's
star power like kill ac and the other
guys hit it hit it
no no but yeah i you know but to put
that out there and and i didn't
going into it i was like i don't need
people to mosh i just want people to
like
hear my music that's that that's what i
wanted i want people to hear
what me
and my band have come together and
created that's what but but people were
like
with it and when you see people like
bobbing their head to that it's it's
kind of crazy
because i've always been on the other
end i've always been on the other end
i've been going to concerts and all this
stuff and you know loving music and i
you know
listen i tried to do the band thing when
i was younger i tried to do it you know
i had a ska band for a hot second you
know everybody like scott you know let
me give let me give my best trumpet
impression
that sounded like the price is right
i did oh
did not bad pretty good yeah pretty good
but you know we were young we were like
15 when we started that and
you know it didn't work out because it
was just like i'll say oh you got to get
like a bunch of people together to like
do this i was like everybody's got to
kind of be on the same page and
i was just exhausted you know to try to
like gather up people all the time like
we always
had someone that was in and there's
someone that didn't want to be in also
like like i said we were in junior high
or no sorry
um
oh no it wasn't when i was 15. so yeah
junior high so i was like 13 or 14.
um
but anyways needless to say like yeah it
was
you know it was just annoying but to be
able to do it now and it's like you know
me and the guys like came together
pretty much built it off like you know
hey there's no pressure like
you know let's just make
some good music that's like like let's
actually just be good at it and make it
like the least stressful thing possible
possible and
going into that going into it like that
made it to where we were able to like
deliver and have it like a good show
because yeah we didn't and the guys that
i'm in a band that are in my band
they've all been in bands before they've
all done this
you know like in to where they've
actually gotten to perform
songs that they've actually like written
you know whereas i i haven't but to be
yeah to be on the other end and be and
let alone be a front man
yeah that front man energy
yeah
yeah cause it's like
you know like i don't know it's it's
it's it's a lot but it's dope
you know i i
i think i've always had it in me
i think i've always had this thing in me
and and
i don't think it's weird that i um
uh
am doing music
you know what i mean like you know some
people like go do something that's just
kind of
that's just kind of been like the core
of me in general it's just music yeah it
doesn't seem forced yeah it's not it's
not a forced thing it's not like hey you
know and it wasn't like people were like
hey hey you should you should start a
band you should create a band no
we originally started this group because
it was the pandemic everything was shut
down
in la
except for like practice uh spaces and
studios and stuff like that so
for
for us we were just like hey let's get
together and do some cover songs and
film it
you know and we tried that and then the
the filming didn't work out as as best
as like we wanted to
so like we just kind of like that's kind
of like unseen footage
but um
maybe i'll bring maybe i'll bring it out
of the
vault one day
you know
it's it's the prince in me you know
prince has this vault of music that is
just unreleased never heard maybe i
might do that with it
maybe i could be like that i don't know
maybe maybe i am the artist formerly
known as
i know you hate bob dylan but the bob
dylan had the basement tapes oh he did
kind of deal yeah i didn't say i hated
him no i know but you
hated on him oh you said he would put
you to sleep i did so i haven't thought
about it every day i like the wall
flowers
jacob dylan
i saw the one song one headlight yeah
yeah
same here that's all he saw i know but
anyways uh what was that what was i
talking about
band yes
uh
i don't know like i don't i don't have
many words as much as i just really
really really uh
it was it was a it was a great
experience
people were super receptive to it crazy
thing you ready for this
you ready for this i think so okay
the first
album like i bought like a set of four
albums together
and one of those albums was gbh
city babies revenge 101 ways to kill a
rat
first record i bought and i only
purchased it because i like the way the
album cover looked and i was just in the
punk section
at this record store back home in mesa
called well it's not there anymore it
was called rockaway records but i was i
was you know locked in i was like oh
this cool looking record and then i
heard it and i listened to it and i was
like i like this [ __ ] band
i love this [ __ ] band and i was what
14 when i did that okay
you ready for this
so that and i told you earlier that's
the band the
neck and neck with the foo fighters the
bands i've seen the most you ready for
this i'm ready the bass player of that
band came to my show what
yeah dude that's awesome where's the
[ __ ] confetti
we'll put it in post yeah we'll put it
yeah we'll put it we'll put the confetti
in post but man yes
crazy so i didn't even know
so i
this how crazy this [ __ ] world is so
i've i follow him on social media and i
always have you know i love that band i
mean gbh is one of my top favorite bands
and
um
i didn't realize he followed me back
i didn't realize he had or had been
following me
you know
and
i posted about you know hey my band's
playing the show blah blah blah
and he
said i'll be there
and i was like oh okay you know i was
like well i didn't know you followed me
or whatever
literally standing in the parking lot
well
he walks up
and first time you met him i'm assuming
first time i met him well no i met him
like as a fan like years ago when i was
the first time i saw them live
i met i met them uh
i begged my way backstage just to say hi
to the guy because i was like i love
this way so much and i remember that
rhodey was like he's like hold the [ __ ]
up
i can't do i can't it wasn't bad it was
all right anyways but yeah he like i
remember he like yelled at me because i
was like begging so much because i
[ __ ] told you i'll show you you know
whatever and then i was like okay and
then he goes all right man come on back
here like he literally like it was like
he went from like
to like all right man come on back here
and i got to meet them that was so that
was the
you know one and only time i actually
got to meet them but i've seen them so
many [ __ ] times anytime they come to
arizona i would see them and to have
that dude at my
first show ever as a band
what
throw me off a mountain
don't but throw me
you know
what
it was
that's crazy did you get to talk to him
after the show dude he came right up
yeah he he was all he goes i look i
loved it like he was he was all about it
wow he was having a time of his life he
i'm sitting here like
what
it was it was it's insane casey
you got to see gvh pull up a picture of
gbh
let me show you what these guys look
like
let me show you young photo first
yeah
uh the top or what are the top ones
look at that
[Laughter]
so which one of these dudes who's the
left all the way left yeah
sorry yeah i guess that yeah
all the way left
and then uh
let's see a picture of them now
yep so he's right there in the glasses
yeah
so crazy
he was so funny dude he's telling me
when he moved to
california he lives here he lives in
california
uh
he moved
to like western and something or
whatever
he didn't realize
it was a crypt neighborhood
and he didn't even realize what the
crips were
he said they're called the roland 30s
i'm sorry why am i
i'm not going to do any more british
accents he said there were the rolling
30s and he like which is
a [ __ ] gang like you usually if like
it's like rolling i guess i don't i
don't know whatever
but he he didn't know
and i just think that's hilarious that
he flew all the way to america it moved
right into a [ __ ] territory
it had no clue
what it was
and then that moment hits him he's like
i don't know something
something might be going on
was there one in blue
[Laughter]
but anyways needless to say
dope that he came and
showed a lot of support a lot of people
a lot of people came
a lot of uh oh yeah this is the first
song we perform before i tell you before
i get into this
with this video
singing is hard
and singing that way
and like moving around
is really hard
really really hard i uh
i think i need to like obviously i it's
the lung capacity because i'm like i
can't finish my words on the first song
i do fine
but like as i like as we were going
through the set like my words weren't
like finishing
i'm sitting here while i was watching
and critiquing myself as i do with
anything and everything i do that's how
you get better
20 000 hours
so anyways
i think it's 10 000.
yeah i think the phrase is 10 000. 1000
hours
i don't know ten thousand dollars to the
power yeah uh twenty thousand twices
twenty yeah twenty yeah if you're doing
twenty thousand
even better
you're you're uh a mastermind yeah but
yes it's really hard singing and moving
around that way and i like to move
around because i'm like man i feel these
songs and i feel what you know what it
is and
you know
and i wrote them to be able to feel like
yeah off of it too
so yeah i was like i couldn't finish my
words
you know it's
so the first song so we'll watch a
little bit of the first song and then
i'll show you the last song we did
you'll be able to understand okay it's
like round one versus round five oh my
god
[Laughter]
it's literally like that all right let's
take a look
[Music]
ice cube long sleeve by the way
this is so dope like just being in that
environment
i'm like not blowing myself up
okay so you hear this one the last one i
sent you a text
it's a youtube video
it's uh
yeah
so click that one you got to fast
forward a little bit because i'm like
talking a lot because i'm trying to kill
time so fast forward
to like a minute and maybe
i'm tired
[Music]
there's a difference
wait you slightly hear it
no
i can't tell
oh i could feel it
oh no i know when you'll be able to hear
it fast forward
go back a little bit go back
right here
[Music]
could you hear it a little bit no i
wouldn't have am i tripping if you
didn't if you hadn't said anything i
don't think you know what i noticed
watch how tired i get
so i'm lost with people you know he's
like let me watch a little bit
[Music]
okay
now watch that watch me and there we go
hands on the knees hands on the knees
sign your guess
that looks like you're like yeah i'm
doing i'm doing like a pose you're like
i am about to pass out yes
yes and shout out to toby morris because
toby was like he goes you did a smart
move i saw that i was like what he goes
because i knew you were tired
he goes you wouldn't stand by the drum
set he goes but you did this thing where
he looked at the crowd and was just like
yeah
and you're right the face was still
performing the face was still possible
back to cheerleading back to
casey
rolling today
veteran move out of you gosh i need to
keep up with casey get you get you a
casey in your life if you don't have a
casey in your life then you're probably
not doing as great mm-hmm oh that and
i'll say that
so but yeah knowing how to utilize the
face
minimize the body movement recover
recover still perform still perform
recover recover a lot of recovery
so much recovery
the most recovery
it was tough man but but it was super
fun i was like man i need
but
listen anything and everything i want to
do
i want to do it good and i want to be
really good at it so yes i
you may look at it and go like hey you
know oh it doesn't sound bad at all but
i'm just so damn critical of myself and
i i just i want to be i want to deliver
my best you know and i think it but not
diminishing your
you know discrediting the fact that you
say oh i don't really hear anything
don't think that you know it
why what were you going to say oh i was
just going to ask what toby thought
after the show like what was his kind of
report card oh he was just like he goes
you guys are a good man because i i held
out on showing him
any of the music i was like made you
know one of his any and he didn't want
me to show
the music you know
but he's he immediately he's like yo he
goes you guys could for sure open up for
my band
whoa yeah yeah he goes he goes you guys
are like he goes you guys are really
really good that's awesome he was he was
super impressed he was super super
impressed it was it was dope to hear
that you know
it it um
especially coming from him i mean
i mean listen like
gbh has been a band for like 40 years um
h2o's been a band for like 26 years
uh i mean there's there's quite a few
people in the house that have been
doing the band stuff for like years
so they hear like their genuine feedback
and understanding it's it's like oh wow
like
you know it it feels good got to be
encouraging yeah for sure
and here here's another thing
the the thing about me is yes i i do
come from somewhere from from a place to
where i've built a platform
off of being a stand-up comedian but
also like i do love talking about music
and i'll probably get opportunities
that
you know
that bands that have been you know that
are starting out that are really trying
won't get as quick as i probably would
you know what i mean
and so i feel like i have to like really
really really really genuinely
and do deliver my best
because of that you know and and not
like [ __ ] like
you know just be a
you know just be kind of regular with it
you know because anyone can say oh i
want to start a band
you know what i mean anybody can just go
out there and like
do that but like to take it serious and
you know
i i do want to show respect for the
people that
this is their
main thing this is their only thing
you know what i mean i do a lot of
things but for some people this is
literally their only thing does that
make sense yeah totally you know and
yeah like i said like i'll probably get
opportunities
quicker than most based off of like
oh it's chapelle lacy and based on
people that already know
from the music world yeah but the fact
that you are already recognizing that
and not taking it for granted i think
is a good sign and it's all good well
that happens that happens a lot you know
you see it happen like you know with a
lot of people and people that that this
is their like they live off this they
you know sacrificing so much to do
do this
and um
you just see people kind of stomp over
that and not acknowledge that and i
think that's the thing that's important
to acknowledge like like there's good
bands out there that are probably just
as good as mine or better even better
than mine you know what i mean they're
probably gonna you know that probably
haven't caught like some type of break
yet
you know but like
that's why that's why i you know for me
personally i would just try to just make
it apparent to like do my best to show
those bands respect and i think
acknowledging that and understanding
that and also uh
just being the best musician that i can
be
also like shows that respect
you know what i mean does that make
sense i feel it yeah i feel that
yeah
that came out they came out right yeah
i know
[Laughter]
listen casey is not only the producer
he's also my teacher
listen y'all don't realize i'm taking
classes
with casey while we're recording as well
it gives me the whole breakdown of
everything
my my my grammar
my
math
uh my uh
science
all the above social that's why he has
that's why he has the the computer yeah
right there social studies yeah if i
geography if i need to know where
you know something is that i don't know
on the map
my teacher
right here casey um
yeah uh i don't even know how to explain
our band
as much as i could explain like who i've
been inspired by
to write the songs that i write
i mean but that's like that's like a
long list
you know
i think i think okay
top three top five
i'd say
this man refused
from
sweden
black flag
as weird as it may sound
and as much as people are probably gonna
probably want to punch me in the face
from this but you're not going to
because i'll drop kick in your chest uh
oasis
how though it seems like such a
different so
there's one song
that uh
the last song we performed the last song
that i
the last song that i wrote or whatever
um
[Music]
i got inspired for the ending of our
song from an oasis song
there's this one oasis song called bring
it on down
and
uh no gallagher at the end goes off on a
solo
that's so dope
and so
the song i wrote it's it's it's more
towards punk
and hardcore
and so i told my lead guitarist chris
i was just like
go off
just go off
and like solo a long time and let the
man just hold it out
and then you
give give the
the rest of the song life
you know like keep it give it more life
or whatever
and uh that was inspired off an oasis
song
boom
see what i did there
uh so oasis
oddly enough
um
i would say ice cube
yeah
i would say ice cube
and then
how many did i name four did i
did i did i
oh
oh did i
uh
fifth one
oh i would say uh gbh
um so casey
yeah i have a metal update
has a metal update yes so my okay let's
hear it on my homework assignment last
week was to try and acclimate myself to
metal right okay i'm more than willing
to be a participant yes in this
experiment
my cousin was also like case give metal
a shot because we talked about my cousin
yeah yeah your cousin yep shout out to
chris shout out to chris denman um so
you were like uh
what's a good entry-level medal right
and you said pantera so i'm home
i'm having a couple beers or whatever
and i'm like all right i'm gonna do my
metal homework here we go setting aside
some time for my metal homework yeah so
i throw on some pantera
first song i'm like all right i could
get into this um second song comes on
not only do i know this song i know
every word to this song
[Laughter]
i was it walk yep
how did you know
because i remember the record i told you
to listen to and you said the second
song
and that's the second song on that album
right yeah right yeah yeah i think so
yeah i didn't know i thought the name of
that song was um
like respect because that's what they
repeat about r-e-s-v-c-d
you find out what's like something that
says
you know i'm a little bit trepidation
and then it comes out it's like this is
like one of my favorite songs yeah yeah
cause it was in a skate video so i have
that association
yeah yeah a million times uh-huh so
i know every word to that yeah this is
gonna be easy
i might be
yeah a metal head is that what we're
called yes you're you are a metal head
and someone gave me and people gave me
other things that like they're like yo
just tell casey to listen to this start
off here start off here and i was like
which is which was fair
um
like a little bit before um
metallica oh okay is a good starter
starter kit to metal
uh i'm
for me i recommend the first record kill
them all because that's my favorite
metallica record is that my next
homework assignment
no your next homework is not you should
watch the oasis doc
that's not metal
oh yeah you're right it's a whole
different uh you know assignment we'll
get there
all right stay focused you're right
you're right you're right you're right
you're right wasn't that cool i was like
yeah i'm gonna give this a chance sexy
yeah every word yeah so the thing about
pantera like to me
i think pantera is one of those bands
where
i would say
they were one of the more consistent
bands when it came to like making albums
you know
that's why it was kind of hard for me to
like choose like which album for you to
go to
because to me personally
i think
all their albums are really really good
albums and i it just and what's dope
about them being good albums they're
they're great musicians like they're
good
they're good band you know so that's why
i was like kind of hard to like figure
out but like uh yeah metallica
actually metallica yeah there's some
hit us in the comments what's my next
assignment yeah yeah what yeah
yeah in the comments we're going to try
to figure out what casey's next
assignment should be also so i went so i
was home drinking literally yeah that
was like pre-gaming before i went and
hung out uh my friend's house yeah so i
was so into it that i go to my friend's
house and i put that song on like later
in the night or whatever yeah and the
vibe had not been that way up until that
point and i'm like i'm going to put a
you know a stick in the spoke here and
like take us on a tangent
it didn't work it didn't take
like the song's giving me a headache oh
gosh she ultimately left because she had
a headache she was a yeah she had the
headache prior to going in there it
wasn't a medal it wasn't a mental
headache there's no such thing as a men
what doctors ever what doctors ever said
oh i think you're diagnosed diagnosed
you with a mental headache yeah never
happened let me you got to hit let me
ask you this are you listening to a lot
of metal no the doctor yeah yeah yeah
exactly are you
you know i'm just trying to
narrow this down are you losing a lot of
metal yeah why you're have you
experienced that though like you try and
set like
because that can be a device no i
actually i actually whenever someone's
in my car or whatever i normally don't
play any of the stuff that i would
normally play
like i have a playlist for when people
that's kind of universal
for when someone like gets in my car
unless that person is down with that
music like me and toby it's just like
everything yeah but like
anyone else like it's usually like i go
let me just hit you with this and be
nice
let me let me let me be let me not be so
selfish
and [ __ ] just deliver this
universal playlist to you because
literally
i i want to listen to my music all the
time but a lot of times
because then it's like the vive is weird
in the car and
you're driving
it's so it's so one way
it's so one way
so yeah i mean i get it now that i'm a
metal hat so yeah guys he's a metal head
they better photoshop you into like some
like metal concert or something uh
that's good yeah so then yeah i would
take check out yeah metallica kill em
all
and ride the lightning um
i don't know there's i mean yeah do yeah
do those just do those who who makes
that uh hell's bells song
that's acdc is that metal hails bills
you know i don't know if i don't know if
people would put that as metal as much
as they would
a lot of metal bands would say they were
inspired by that song okay yeah that's
just that makes sense
yeah that's like just yeah good rock
that's just rock and roll like when i
think of like done dirt cheap which is
my favorite ac dc song
like
that's just good that's just a good rock
song
but it like it's it's heavy enough to
where it
you know
i could understand like some metal band
getting inspired off of that song to
find that like that that heaviness
so i hope that wasn't a dumb question
i'm going to have a live
question hey everybody everybody could
eat a dick there's no dumb question in
this class
[Laughter]
uh the student has become the teacher
yeah
didn't bruce lee say that yes he did i
don't know oh whatever whatever
uh okay so hey i have a chappelle shout
out of the week yeah
well yeah new segment charles shout out
to the week
um
and i can't believe we didn't even catch
this yeah this one i saw this one in the
comments yeah he's the casey found this
in the comments from michael morales
that's just his name on youtube oh he
wants to create his youtube like when it
first came back
to have the youtube name michael morales
back when the internet was created
let's talk about a callback he's he's
rolling casey's role
uh he he commented
lacey and casey got dope chemistry how
did we not think how did we not think of
lacy and casey
that's what i love about fans they be
paying attention smart
they are smarter than a fifth grader
yeah they are not the weakest link
um what's the other one
that was head regis
they want to be who wants to be yeah
yeah they want to be a millionaire they
want to be him out here uh
everybody's seeing casey i read that i
was like i was
i laughed but then i was like pissed i
was like how do we yeah yeah yeah
because it's like it's frustrating
because it's like wait what right there
you mean to tell me there's a lacey and
casey
uh chemistry thing that we could have
found that we did not i don't know how
the odd couple it's like the the odd
couple or uh perfect strangers yeah you
know that show yeah and larry
chicago i believe
yes yeah
want to know a fun fact hell yeah
you did you know
family matters is a spin-off of that
show what yes which character is like
the uh the mom of uh family matters
worked
at the building or something that yeah
crazy that's wild i just blew your mind
yeah tap your brain and blow your mind
uh so that's our shout out for a week
now let's get into this playlist
um
so this playlist i'll specifically do
i'm gonna make a foo fighters playlist
i'm gonna do some of my favorite
foo fighter songs appropriate um
you know
i'll start with um
i'll start with a foo fighters b side
and it's called empty handed
um
i'll do
bridge burning
i'll do my poor brain
the first record dave did by him by
himself did you know that
damn i thought you did uh good grief
i like break out let's do breakout
it's so funny my uh i'm just such a deep
cut guy
overdrive
first cut is the d
we'll do monkey wrench i like monkey
wrench
rope let's do rope
uh
oh i like that uh off one of their later
albums i like the song run
we'll top it off
with my hero
what a way to top it now
um
all right
so that's the playlist for the week
enjoy that one listen to some of the
listen to those deep cuts
of the foods
and enjoy that um
i got some tour dates coming up please
come see me live i swear i'm a funny guy
listen i know i don't have a lot of
material out there for you guys to see
to trust the fact that you should come
see me live
but i swear i'm funny
you have a good time
i make my shows really really fun
please
the thirstiest i don't take tour dates
april 8th and april 9th
now april 8th and april 9th i mean salt
lake city at wiseguys comedy club uh
which is oh that's next weekend and then
may 6th and may 2 may 7th new comedy
club in san diego called mic drop comedy
club i'll be there as well um and then
one night i'm doing a one-nighter in
phoenix in the hometown may 12th
uh if listen if i'm there for one night
phoenix and if i
don't sell out my hometown i'll kick you
in the dick
all right and will lion say that you did
yeah i will lie i'll come back i'm like
man they showed me all of their like
hometown hero hometown hero
yeah yeah full treatment yeah a whole
treatment
they're freeing me grapes whenever i
wanted to had a feather fan oh very
grecian yeah um so yeah one-nighter
there and then i just added june 24th
and 25th i'll be in rhode island at the
comedy connection uh meatball will be
hanging out with me
and so those are my tour dates anything
um or i guess stay tuned for mad
peaceful's next gig oh yeah stay tuned
for mad peaceful next next gig uh we
don't know we
we want to record
because it's like people don't have any
songs that they could just listen to of
ours so i'd rather give these people
something they can listen to before they
just come to another show it's like how
i have to do with stand up you know like
show a clip of you doing stand-up and
whatever
just you can't just be like just trust
me i don't know
yeah trust the kid
all right thank you guys appreciate it
you